مساء الخير رغم مرور عشره ايام على قرار
الرئيس الامريكي المفاجئ بالانسحاب من
سوريا لكن مازال كل صناع القرار
والمتابعين والخبراء في عواصم العالم
كلها في حزب محاوله لفهم اسباب ودوافع
القرار الحقيقيه ونتائج والاهم ان
الانسحاب حقيقي ولا مجرد مناوره اللي كان
بيدور في ذهن الرئيس الامريكي الله اعلم
ولكن المؤكد انه لا يخرج عن ثلاثه
احتمالات وهو ده
يلخص كل ما كتب في العواصم الرئيسيه او
يعبر عن ما قيل في العاصمه الرئيسيه
العاصمه الرئيسيه معنا الى ستكون درس اللي
هم المعنيين ب قرار الانسحاب في طهران وفي
انقره في العواصم الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده اجمالا كل ما قيل ممكن نلخص في
ثلاث احتمالات
الاحتمال الاول ان ي ان الولايات المتحده
قررت الانسحاب بسبب انتهاء المهمه المكلف
بها القوات الامريكيه هناك
والاحتمال الثاني هو ان الولايات المتحده
لم تنسحب ولكن لها قررت الخروج حربا
لفشلها في اتمام المهمه
والاحتمال الثالث انه المساله لا انسحاب
ولا هروب ولكن مناوره من جانب الرئيس
الامريكي لتحقيق عدد من المعارض والاهداف
الاخرى لما ان نلخص كل واحده كده الضوء
عليها باختصار شديد نشوف ان وجهه النظر
الاولنيه اللي هو الانسحاب الانتهاء
المهمه او ال اتمام المهمه ال مقتنع به
هو مقتنع ب وجهه النظر الرسميه او الروايه
الرسميه للبيت الابيض الرئيس دون التمهيدي
اقول انه هذه القوات الموجوده منذ 2015
بقرار من الرئيس السابق اوبا ما جاءت الى
هدف محدد وهذا الهدف هو
القضاء على داعش اللي نجحت في 2014 فانها
تكتسح
مساحات واسعه من العراق وسوريا ونجحت في
تاسيس عاصمه لها في الشرق السوري
مدينه الرقه والمهمه للقضاء على داعش و
بيقول انا اتممت هذه المهمه وبالتالي لم
يعد موجوده هناك اي مبرر لكن في وجهه نظر
التاليه داخل الولايات المتحده من بتناقش
ترفض وجهه نظر الرئيس الامريكي وبتقول
انه انت يجب ان تكون موجود هناك لفترات
اطول ان المهمه لم تنته كليه وب ينتقدوا
القرار واللي بين تاخذ القرار دول المناسب
س يعني من خارج الاداره الامريكيه يقول من
اقطاب الاداره الامريكيه نفسها وعلى راسهم
وزير الدفاع المستقيل المهندس الخلاف ما
بين وجهتين النظر اللي بيمثل ها في الوقت
الحالي ووزير الدفاع المستقيل بس هي سرعه
قديم داخل الولايات المتحده
ويمثل خلاف قديم عمره ميه الساعه
بيقول ايه باختصار شديد هل دور الولايات
المتحده هي ان تكون قائد العالم وجهه نظر
وزير الدفاع ومئات من العسكريين وال اعضاء
الكونغرس والكتاب والمفكرين نعم وانهى
لازم يكون عنده اقوى في سوريا وفي العراق
وفي شرق اسيا في كل مكان وفي ثقه وفي كل
مكان الان دور الولايات المتحده
كقائد للعالم يقتدى هذا وحتى وانت كلفت
الكثير
ودي الطريقه الوحيده لحمايه مصالح كقوه
عظمى وان القوات سيكون موجوده على الارض
وفي الفضاء وفي كل مكان وجهه النظر
الثانيه اللي كانت موجوده وان حصرت ثم
عادت مره اخرى مع زكور تم
والفكره الانعزال ان رافع بها شعر امريكا
اولا يعني باختصار اعدتني بشؤون انا
الاولى والرئيس الامريكي قالها بطريقه
يعني واضحه جدا وبطريقه صادمه في 2016
اثناء حمله الانتخابيه لما قال ان امريكا
بلا الفقير ولم تعد قادره على تحمل كل هذه
النفقات وبدل ما انا انفق الاموال على
يعني اه مواجهه طالبان في افغانستان وداع
في سوريا وخلافه الافضل لنا ان في قطاع
البنيه التحتيه وعلى الاستثمار والتنميه
داخل امريكا وكان النظر بيعتقد انه هو دخل
البيت الابيض ناس كثيره من الشعب الحقيقي
مش اصحاب المصالح مؤمن بهذا الكلام عموما
دي كلها على بعض كدا الانسحاب ال اتمام
المهمه
سواء كان الناس مقتنعين بها او مش مقتنعين
بها السبب الاول والخروج من المدينه
النظره الثانيه في تفسير الخروج من سوريا
بيقول ان المساله لم تكن انسحابا لاتمام
المهمه ولكن هربا من الحرب ا من الفشل
وبسبب الفشل في اتمام المهمه وقت اللي
بتقول ان الرئيس الامريكي شاف ان بعد اربع
سنين من التواجد هناك انه المساله
انه صحيح انه تم القضاء على الجزء الاكبر
من داعش وقوامها لكن بعد اربع سنين
التقديرات الامريكيه بتقول ان هناك من
عشره الى عشرين الف عنصر تابع يداعب
موجودين ما بين العراق وسوريا خلاف اليوم
عنصر موجوده في الشمال الفقهيه وموجوده في
يعني الدول الافريقيه مختلفه وفي شرق اسيا
وان المدى القادم قادم الى داعش داعش مرضت
فلم تموت لان الفكره قائمه
وتتغذى على افكار ما تشيلسي اضف الى ذلك
ان
انه عشان يقضي على الجزء ال متاكده معناها
انه يظل في سوريا الى ما شاء الله ويصلي
في افغانستان الى ما شاء الله المواجهه
ومواجهه الطالبان ثم انه اضيفت اهداف اخرى
الى فتنه القضاء على داعش مهمه اخرى
للقوات الموجوده في سوريا مثلا حتى الخطر
الايراني
ومجابهه او يعني وضع توازن مع القوات
الروسيه وحمايه الاكراد ومساعده
الاسرائيليين كل دي مهام تعني انه سوف يصل
الى ما شاء الله الرئيس الامريكي اللي هو
مقتنع بفكره امريكا اولا وتقليص النفقات
يلاحظ ان النفقات في السريه تزداد يوما
بعد يوم يعني بداوا في 2015 بتكلفه حوالي
سته مليارات التكلفه اللي محدوده في
الفيلم تسعطاشر القوات السوريه في القوات
الامريكيه في سوريا
15 15 مليار و 300 مليون
والتكلفه لما تجمع الاربع سنوات تصل الى
حوالي خمسين مليار دولار واذا اضفت للصوره
وسعت الصوره وشفت افغانستان لانها قررت
سحب القوات الامريكيه من سوريا ونصف
القوات الامريكيه العدد 14
سبعه الاف المطلوب وزنه القوات الامريكيه
هناك سته وسبعين مليار دولار ومؤهله او
مرشحه للزياده بنقل على الطلب البنتاغون
ما يعني ان الرقم سته وسبعين كل موظف
الدفاع البلد بريطانيا العظمى نفسها
وبالتالي هو شيخ الي المساله مستحيل
استكملها او الوفاء بهذه المطالب بقرار
الحرب وليس
الانسحاب لاتمام المهمه هل هذه سابقه في
ال يعني ال التاريخ الامريكي لا في سوابق
للذاكره قرار الرئيس اوباما في اغسطس 2010
حين اعلن انسحاب القوات الامريكيه من
العراق اللي تم على مراحل بعد كده لانتهاء
المهمه لكن واقع الامر ان المهمه لم تكن
قد انتهى وان الفوضى كانت تضرب العراق لكن
هو مش قادر يقول كده فهل ان المهمه انتهت
وتقرر الهروب ولولا ظهور داعش كان انسحب
الاقرب الى ما فعله اضراب يوم 19 ديسمبر
هو اللي كان عملوا الرئيس نيكسون في اه
يناير سنه ثلاثه وسبعين لما اعلم الخروج
من فيتنام
معلنا تحقيق النصر اتمام المهمه
كل الكلام الجميل ده في واقع الامر هو
تنهار بان
وبيحاول لانه المهمه بعد طناشر سنه حرب
وثمانيه وخمسين الف جندي قطره في المعركه
و مئات الالوف من الفتنه الفا من اهالي
فيتنام المهمه فاضطر الامه ينهي المهمه
بطريق تقول ان الحرب انتهت والمهام انتهت
ويخرج
هذا ما فعله
التفصيل الثالث للخروج الامريكي المفاجئ
من سوريا بيقول انه لا المساله انسحاب ال
اتمام المهمه ولا هربا من انتهاء المهمه
لان الانسحاب لن يتم بالفعل يعني لا يمكن
ان يتم بسبب ضغوط من اسرائيل والضغوط
البنتاغون وبسبب الاعتبارات الكثيره التي
يتم وانه الفتره كلها انه الاعلان على
الانسحاب والبدء الانسحاب الفعلي ليس الا
مناوره على طريقه الرئيس الامريكي في وجهه
نظره ايه طريقه الرئيس الامريكي اذا كنت
جالس على ما الى المفاوضات
وفي صعوبه في اقناع الاخرين بوجهه نظره
افضل طريقه انك تقل بالمائه كلها على رؤوس
الجالسين وتغادر الغرفه املا في اقناع
جديده في توصيل الجهه نظره يخفضوا من سقف
توقعاتكم اذا كانوا عاوزين يتفاوضوا معك
عمل الكلام دافعين عملوا في الاتفاق
النووي هو عاوز هو مقتنع ملازمه يتواصل مع
الايرانيين بس هو مقتنع انه افضل طريقه
للتفاوض معهم مش اللي عملوا بعمل انه يلغي
الاتفاق ويذهب الى اقصى ال يعني اليمين او
اليسار وبعد الغاء الاتفاق نبدا من جديد
اتفاق سقف توقعات منخفض من كان بايران
وعمل الكلام دا لما الاخ الاتفاق التجاريه
مع المكسيك وكانت
اسف وعمل الكلام ده مع الصين لما فرض
عليهم العقوبات بدون تفاوضات جديده عمل
الكلام ده وعملوا الكلام دا مع الاوروبيين
لما قال لهم انا غير مقتنع به حلف الناتو
من اساسه في طريقه في التص
باعلان الانسحاب
اطراف كثيره بامور كثيره بعضها بنعرف في
العالم العربي وبعدها ما بنعرف وس يعني
مثلا هو عنده مشكله كبيره مع البنتاغون ان
البنتاغون طول الوقت بيطلب زياده في
النفقات وزاريه الولايات المتحده في 2017
كانت مليار ومائتين مليار
خمسين في المائه منها للبنتاغون والخمسين
في المائه الاخرى هي او خمسين في المائه
من ها الدفاع يعني ا بصفه عامه والخمسين
في المائه اخرى للتعليم والصحه والبنيه
التحتيه ولكل الاغراض الاخرى في الحقيقه
وفي الفيلم وز الموازنه اللي بعد 2018
المخصصات الميزانيه الجديده بمائه مليار
اصبح مخصصات الدفاع سبعمائه مليار دولار
وطوال الوقت الان تقول بيطلب زياده في
النفقات وعنده مشكله كمان في يعني يعني
طوال الوقت القصه محليه قويه في انه مش
قادرين
تعيين بشركه حسابات تثبت او
تقول ان فقد كلها بدقه بتحسين وزاي ولا
تغيره طيب هو مش
مقتنع بهذا الامر هو مقتنع بضروره خفضه
هذه النفقات لاسباب كثيره اربعه في اداره
اخرهم استقاله لانهم مصرين على انه يجب
زياده النفقات هو خايف ان هؤلاء الجنرالات
بيدافع عن مصالح الجيش وليس مصالح امريكا
او على الاقل ليست مصالح امريكا كما يراها
يقنعهم الزاي بعد تفاوض الفتره ولا لهم
طبعا انسحب من سوريا كليه واصحاب نصف
القوات من افغانستان وهذا حقيقه القوات في
وقت قريب وبالتالي
ان تكون جدا البنتاغون موظفين فانها
اهميتهم والتي مشعل يستقيل لكن المساله مش
بالبساطه دي لانه البنتاغون بيعبر عن
مصالح شركه ضخمه جدا والشركه التي تمول
اعضاء في مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
وبالتالي صعبه جدا
الطريقه اللي ممكن يحاول او فكر فيها وفقا
لوجهه النظر انه يخفض توقعاتهم بشكل كبير
جدا ويستفيد امور اخرى انه يضغط على كل
اعضاء الكونغرس اللي
بيعني مشروعه في امور اخرى بان اذا انت
موافق على الامور دي انا بحدد كما تفقد
مصالح كثيره مكاسب كثيره من وجود القوات
الامريكيه بشكل مبرر او بشكل غير مبرر
فعلا كثيره امريكا الان
فاللي حصل ان اتكلم حضراتكم فيها تحارب
على في سبع دول سبعه الدول وهي لا تعاني
من خطر كبير
وكمان يستغل الانسحاب في سوريا لاعاده
التفاوض مع السعوديه اللي ب يقنعها وحول
للتفاوض معها انها تزود نفقاتها وت تحمل
نفقات اكبر في جهود الحرب وفي جهود ال
اعاده البناء
مليون ولا مائتين مليون رقم بسيط جدا
بالنسبه لل تبعات طيب طول الوقت في
مفاوضات
زياده مائتين زياده الانسحاب معناها الوضع
السعوديه ودول اخرى في مازق انا انسحب
المشكل احنا نقول وقت الحرب عندو مش
مقتنعين
تعالوا حل المشكله فاكيد يؤدي الى النوم
السعوديه والدول الخليجيه اخرى سوف تكون
مضطره ان تضاعف الرقم الذي ستحتاجه القوات
الامريكيه حتى تبقى نفس القصه مع اسرائيل
تحب اسرائيل و حلفائنا لكننا نحتاج دعما
اكثر منكم والدعم ده ممكن اقتنعوا بتقديم
واذا انسحبنا بالكامل
الفكره الرئيس الامريكي مره اخرى انه
الاقناع بالطريقه الصباح في امريكانيه في
اطار انه الرئيس الامريكي بيحاول يقنع
البنتاغون تخفيض النفقات بيقولوا انه بدها
مسائل الدائره بها على اكثر من سنه انه
فيه احيانا وجود القوات النظاميه وتكلف
جدا جدا ومش مجدي بعدنا سبعطاشر سنه
موجودين في افغانستان مطالبين مقدر كبيرا
يكون تخرج ونعطي مهامكم الى شركات
خاصه
اللي كانت موجوده في العراق وادى المؤسس
بقاله فتره الكلام ده من حوالي شهرين
ثلاثه للاندبندنت انا في مفاوضات مع
الرئيس الامريكي احاول اقنعه وجهه نظره
واعتقد انه هو وزير خارجيه مقتنعين انا
ممكن ان نفذ المهمه اللي بيعملها الجيش
الامريكي اكد على طالبان كامله
بفتاه من السته وسبعين مليار دولار اللي
بت خصوم الولايات المتحده للقضاء على
طالبان اعطوني الفلوس وسوف اقوم بالمهمه
بدون وجود قوات امريكيه نظاميه وبدون كل
الضغوط الموجوده على الاداره الامريكيه من
اي خسائر في القوات النظاميه وبتكاليف لا
تذكر ايضا من الاهداف اللى عاوز يعمل ها
البرامج اللي كان بيقوم وقد تتحقق بخطوات
الان فيها الاعلام فيها الانسحاب من سوريا
اللي بياكد وجهات النظر الثالثه انه
الكلام اللي هو ال عضو الكونغرس البارز
قال النهار ده ثلاثين ديسمبر
وحاول اقناعه انه على الاقل عليه ان
في مساله الانسحاب وان الرئيس ابدى مرونه
وتفهما ما يعني
انه مره ثانيه مستعده ان يتفاهموا ان
الانسحاب يعني اقرب قد يكون مقره تهديد و
مناوره ثقيله لاقناع خصوم بما يريد اقناع
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]